LONGTIME VIEWERS-- FOLKS,
LONGTIME VIEWERS OF MY WRIST
WILL KNOW THAT I'VE BEEN WEARING
THIS RED BRACELET FOR
SEVEN YEARS.
IT'S PART OF MY WRISTSTRONG
CAMPAIGN IN WHICH I SINGLE
WRISTEDLY RAISED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
YELLOW RIBBON FUND, WHICH
ASSISTS INJURED SERVICE MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
IT'S A PERFECT FIT.
( APPLAUSE )
BECAUSE I BELIEVE NOTHING SAYS
YELLOW RIBBON LIKE RED
BRACELETS.
WHEN THE IRAQ WAR ENDED IN 2010,
I TOOK ONE WRISTSTRONG BRACELET
OFF, AND NOW I CAN TAKE THE LAST
ONE OFF.
>> THIS MORNING A MILESTONE IN
THE WAR IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE UNITED STATES AND NATO
OFFICIALLY ENDED THEIR COMBAT
MISSION.
>> IN AFGHANISTAN, THE U.S. AND
NATO OFFICIALLY CLOSED THEIR
COMBAT MISSION AFTER MORE THAN
13 YEARS.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Stephen: ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT, THERE WE GO.
HERE WE GO.
BOOM!
NOW, I AM-- I AM SORRY THAT OUR
TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN ARE NOT
GETTING A PARADE LIKE THE ONE
THE IRAQ VETERANS DIDN'T GET.
I DON'T KNOW THE PROBLEM.
THERE MUST BE A WORLDWIDE
CONFETTI SHORTAGE.
SO BEFORE I GO OFF THE AIR, I'M
GOING TO RAISE A LITTLE MORE
GREEN ONE LAST TIME FOR THE
YELLOW RIBBON FUND.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).
TONIGHT, I AM RAFFLING OFF PARTS
OF MY SET.
STEVE, TELL THEM WHAT THEY COULD
WIN.
>> WELL, STEPHEN, THE
FIRST-PLACE WINNER WILL TAKE
HOME THE ACTUAL COLBERT REPORT
DESK, MADE OF 100% GENUINE
MATERIAL.
THIS TIMELESS CLASSIC IS SHAPED
LIKE A GIANT "C," OR A SEVERELY
MISSHAPEN "U."
THIS VERY DESK WITNESSED THE
COUNTLESS HISTORIC MOMENTS ON
THE "COLBERT REPORT," SUCH AS
THE TIME STEPHEN COLBERT
ANNOUNCED THIS RAFFLE.
>> THANKS, STEVE, THAT SOUNDS
LIKE--
>> BUT THAT'S NOT ALL.
THE SECOND-PLACE WINNER UPON
TAKE HOME THIS BEAUTIFUL THE
"COLBERT REPORT" FAKE FIREPLACE,
FEATURING EVERYTHING YOU SEE
HERE-- A GENUINE FAUX MARBLE
MANTEL.
A BUTTER SOFT AND BUTTER-STAINED
LEATHER ARMCHAIR, AND 40-INCH
FLATRON STANDARD DEPTH DISPLAY
WITH ALONG VIDEO OF A ROARING
FIRE.
OH, MY GOD!
I'M ON FIRE!
I'M IN HELL!
AH!
IT BURNS! IT BURNS!
>> Stephen: THANKS STEVE.
TO WIN GO TO
OMAZE.COM/COLBERT, AND YOU'LL
BE ENTERED IN THE RAFFLE FOR
EVERY $10 YOU DONATE.
THE MORE YOU DONATE, THE MORE
CHANCES YOU HAVE TO WIN.
REMEMBER, IT'S ALL FOR A GOOD
CAUSE, BECAUSE THE MONEY WILL BE
SPLIT EQUALLY BETWEEN THE YELLOW
RIBBON FUND, AND OUR FRIENDS AT
DONORS CHOOSE.
BEST OF ALL, YOU'LL BE HELPING
ME CLEAR OUT MY STUDIO BEFORE
NEXT THURSDAY OR I DON'T GET MY
SECURITY DEPOSIT BACK.